ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนที่เหมือน
นาคฟ้าสบายดีไหมดูฟ้า
สบายดีค่ะสบาย
แข็งแรงกินข้าวหรือยัง
กินข้าวแล้วค่ะคนที่ให้
ครูเอ๋วอ่ะคู๋หิวข้าวค่ะ
รู้เองยังไม่กินข้าวหรอคะใช่ค่ะวันนี้ครู
เอ๋ยังไม่กินข้าวเที่ยงหน้าตอนเที่ยงยัง
ไม่กิน
[เพลง]
อยู่ที่ข้าวนิดหน่อยแล้วก็ร้อนด้วย
เข้าเที่ยงยังไม่กินก็ยังไม่อิน
มันเพราะว่ากูเองกินข้าวเช้าจริงๆข้าว
เช้าเนี่ยทานข้าวเช้าต้องกิน
8:00 นใช่ไหม
8:00 น
8:00 นกินข้าวเช้าแล้ววันนี้ครูเอกกิน
ข้าวเช้า 10:00 น
โอ้ว
ก็
ติดหิวไม่หิวไม่หิวไม่หิวตอนนี้4โมงคิว
หน่อย
รู้นิดหน่อยรอด้วยเปิดแอร์ไม่ร้อนเหรอ
พยักอากาศโอเคใช่เห็นนาครูไฟและไฟฟ้ามี
กระดานใช่ไหมงั้นกูฟ้าเขียนก็เพราะวันนี้
วันนี้ตอนนี้ 4 โมง 4 โมงนะคะ 16:00 น
หาต้น 4 โมง 10 นาทีแล้วค่ะคือป่าตอนนี้
ตอนนี้เวลา
[เพลง]
16:10 น
PM มา
4 โมง 10 นาทีนะคะ
ครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้ไหมคะวันศุกร์ค่าเยิ้ม
วันนี้วันตกเท่ากับ 9
วันศุกร์ธรรมดาของคนไปออฟฟิศเย้
เย้วันศุกร์วันศุกร์นะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
อ่ะ
เมื่อวันที่วันที่ 3 ค่ะคนที่ 3
ศุกร์ที่ 3 เลอะๆ
เบื้องเดือนอะไรคะ
ดีอุ้ยเดือนธันวาคมค่ะเดือนธันวาคมอันขาด
มีผชเท่าไหร่เท่าไหร่คะมีอะไร
ปีพตต
2556  4 ค่ะปีพศ
2564 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะมีข้อสอทร์
202  155 ปีค.ศ
2002  1
2021 โอเค
รูปฟ้าวันนี้
มีเกมใหม่ค่ะวันนี้ M ออนไลน์
[เพลง]
เกมส์ออนไลน์อะไรอ่ะเกมออนไลน์
มีของกิน
มีของกินนะอ่ะ
กินเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋ชา screen ก่อนดีกว่าเนาะ
ได้
ของกิน
ของกินอ่ะกูเอกปากกาไปไหนโอเคหาปากกา
เก๋ๆ
ฮะปากกานะไปไหน
ตัดแยกเจอปากกาแล้วเจอแล้ว
วันนี้มีเกมนะคะมีเกมครูฟ้าเราจะมีของกิน
อย่างเช่นอะไรนะไม่เอามีสีของกินส้มเยอะ
ต้ม
อ้าส้มเป็นของกินใช่มั้ยเป็นผลไม้
กินได้อ้ะ
ร้า
ปลาก็เป็นของกินปลาสีส้มกินได้นะอ้า
โทรศัพท์
โทรศัพท์ได้นะโทรศัพท์กินได้มั้ยของอิน
เป็นของอะไรคะโทรศัพท์เป็นของใช้ห่า
โทรศัพท์เป็นของใช้นะคะก็จะมีเองของกิน
ดีของใช้นะคะแต่ว่าครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ครูฟ้าหา
มีอะไรมาครูฟ้าก็ไม่รู้ครูเอ๋มีอะไรต้อง
คิดนะคะมีคำถาม
โอเคไหมมีคำถามได้แล้วก็กูเอกชิ้นหน้านะ
คะละให้ครูมาคิด x อะไรอะไรอะไรนะคะครู
เอ๋ไม่คำถามหนึ่งคำถามโอเค 20 คำถาม ok
go
ok นะอ้า
นักเรียนก็คิดเนาะคิดกูเอ๋มีอะไรนะๆเอา
ของกูเอกก่อนนะคะ
ครูฟ้า
อันนี้อันนี้ครูเอ๋หินแล้วกันค่ะอันที่ 1
เป็นของกิน
เตือนให้
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ผมกินโอเคเอ๋อะไรนะคะก่อนจะถามด้วยจะยิ่ง
แกตัวเองทิ้งก่อน
แอพฟ้าถามก่อนดีกว่าเป็นของหวาน
หรือ
ของอย่าไปไหม
เป็นผลไม้
หรือขนม
กู้ฟ้า
เอาใช้ใช่ไหมดีกว่าไหม
ออกใช่ไหมเป็นคนละไม้ใช่ไหมเป็นผลไม้ใช่
ค่ะ
[เพลง]
เป็นหม่อม
กินผลไม้ให้นักเรียนของ
Apple  Cherry  Berry
ขอเบอร์รี่นะคะ
กูฟ้าได้คิดถึงแอปเปิ้ลเลยอ่ะอ่ะอ่ะ
อ่ะคุยคู๋หินช่วย
สีเหมือนเสื้อครูเอ๋
ใกล้ๆสีใกล้ๆ
มาถามว่าเป็นวงกลมใช่ไหมคะก็รอมั้ยก็ลง
พรมกลม
เป็นวงกลมเล็กใช่ไหมคะเล็กหลัง
อันนี้ใช่ๆเล็กๆ
ฟ้าตอบค่ะเดี๋ยวกูฟ้าถามกี่อันเนี่ยหนึ่ง
เป็นผลไม้ใช่ไหมคะให้มาที่กรมใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะตัวเล็กใช่ไหมคะใช่กู ah  in ว่าสี
เหมือนเสื้อครูเอะคู่ฟ้ารู้แล้วหรอคะ
คิดว่าคิดว่าอะไร
คิดว่า
คิดว่า 3 องุ่นค่ะองุ่น
องุ่นองุ่น
นักเรียนคิดว่าอะไรคะสีม่วง
เล็กๆเป็นผลไม้ครูฟ้ามันยังมีบลูเบอร์รี่
มีอะไรสีม่วงนะองุ่น Tour นะองุ่นชวนัสถ์
ผิดผิดนะ
แต่แต่นะแต่
อะไรคะ
อันนี้คะ
อันนี้คือองุ่นนะคะเอกหน้า
กูไปรู้ได้ยังไงทำไมกูฟารุเพราะครูเอ๋หิน
หาเอ๋เอ๋บอกว่าสีม่วง
สีม่วง
องุ่นมีสีเขียวนะคะกูป่า
อ่ากูคิดว่ามันเป็นเซนน่ะ
เก่งวะ
เก่งมาก
กูฟ้ามีไหมมีหักเห
เปลี่ยนเป็นของกินใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ของกินหรอไม่ใช่ของกินไม่ใช่
ของกินก็เป็นของใช้เนาะอ่ะ
We  Are
ใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะเล็กๆและหรอ
เล็กกา
เล็ก
เวลาใช้ใช้หมื่นจับใช้ไหมคะ
เวลาใช้ใช้มือใช่หาใช้มือจับอื้อ
ใส่ทำไมเดี๋ยวนี้
โอเคใช้
ใช้สำหรับดู
ดูซีรีส์ได้ใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่หรอ
ไม่ใช่เล็กๆหรอคะโอเคใช้กับผมใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่แน่เลยคู่ฟ้าไว้มีอ่ะแต่
ไม่ใช่ห่าเอ๊ยเธอ
โหมันไม่ใช้กับผมเล็กๆ
อาใช้กับตัวไหมคะตัว
ไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ได้ใช้กับตัว
ตัวนี้ฮัลโหลชั่นก็ใช้กับตัวเนาะ
ลิปสติกก็ใช้กับตัวใช่กับป่าเล็กหน่อย
ให้กับปากใช่ไหมคะกินข้าวพูด x นี้
หากไม่ใช่ตัวไม่ใช่หรอ
โอเค kuai รู้เราสอบครูเอ๋ตอบว่า
ลิฟฟิกค่ะ
มิติเรื่องสิใช่ไหมคะคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
เย้หากูเองไม่รู้นะครูบาเอาอะไรมาเนาะอ้า
อีกเนี้ยเป็นของใช้นะคะค่ะให้กับ
ปากให้กับปากมาหาเออ
ของใช้ค่ะอ่า
โอเคคุยนะ
หินสี่เหลี่ยม
[เพลง]
สี่เหลี่ยม
อันนี้ก็
อะไรดีคุยหาอะไรเป็นสี่เหลี่ยม
ซองแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะเนี่ยซองซองก็มีหนึ่ง
เหลี่ยมสองเหลี่ยมสามเหลี่ยมสี่เหลี่ยม
สี่เหลี่ยม
โอเค
เป็นของใช้ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะแต่ถ้า
เล็กใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
หนักใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ไม่หนักนะน่ะ
น่ะเบาเบาๆๆ
ยัง tissue
tissue
โชคก็เบาคุณเบา
อันนี้เบา
ใช้ไปฟ้าไหมคะไฟฟ้าคือปิ้งมี xxx ปลั๊ก
ใช่ไหมคะก็ต้องมีปลั๊กแล้วก็เสียบละไม่
ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช้ไปป๊าไม่ใช้บัตรจะเบาเบาๆ
เปล่าโอเคกูไอ้หิน
หายนายห้องครัว
ไทยในห้องครัวจ้าๆ
เขาครัว
ใช้
ทำความสะอาดใช่ไหมคะอ๋อเวลามีมีถ้วยแล้ว
ส่งกระโปรกที่นี่มี
ใช้ทำความสะอาดทำความสะอาด
ใช่ค่ะ
รู้แล้วเจอไหมเหมือนจะรู้รู้ว่า 60%
ว่า 60% นักเรียนรู้ไหม
name
ขอดอกค่ะตอบว่าอะไรคะ
ฟองน้ำฟองน้ำ
[เพลง]
ฟองน้ำหน้าห้องน้ำหนักเบาเบาๆ
นิดหน่อยจะเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมเนาะสี่เหลี่ยม
สี่เหลี่ยมใช้ล้างทำความสะอาด
ใช้ทักษะความสะอาด
ล้างจานรักเขาก็เอ้อ
คนสะอาดเคาน์เตอร์
ชอบ
[เพลง]
กล่องดาวน้ำตอนน้ำหรือไม่หาก
ครูฟ้ามีของมั้ย
คิดก่อนคิดก่อนออกมีขมิ้น
อะไรก็ได้ค่ะมีละโอเค
เป็นของกินใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่ของกินค่ะกินเป็นของใช้ติดมั้ย
ใช้ไหน
เดี๋ยวนะใช่ Skin ดีกว่าจะได้ว่าได้
[เพลง]
ลบก่อนนะคะลบๆ
ใช้ในห้อง
ห้องนอน
เป็นห้องนอนมีปีและยังมีหมอนหมอนผ้าห่ม
นอนอ่ะ
ใช้ในห้องนอน
ใช่ไหมคะ
ก็ใช่ค่ะห้องนอนโอเค
ห้องครัวโอเค
ใครได้ทุกที่ใช้ได้ทุกที่ใช้ได้ทุกพี่
เพราะว่า
เอาไว้ตอนโอเคห้องครัวครัวอาทินี่มีอ่ะ
ปุ๊บ
มีไฟ
มีกระทะที่ห้องครัวโอเคด้วยหรอ
ครัวโอเคอ๋อออมฟ้ากินนะ
อ่าส่วนใหญ่นะคะใช้ค่ะเต็มกระเป๋า
เวลาไปข้างนอกจะมีติดไว้สมมุติ
ตอนนี้ใช่ไหมตอนนี้ใช่ไหมตอนนี้หรอคือถ้า
เกิดกูฟ้าครูเอ๋ไปนัดไป
อาร์มไปข้างนอกนะคะก็จะมีกระเป๋าค่ะอ่า
นี่กระเป๋าเนี่ยอ้ะสมัครนี้กระเป๋าเฟสว่า
คุยว่ามีกระเป๋า
น้องผู้หญิงผู้หญิงส่วนใหญ่มีกระเป๋า
มีกระเป๋าค่ะ
กระเป๋าค่ะ
เป็นของใช้ออฟต้องใส่ในกระเป๋าหรอคะ
อาคิดมากเวลาไปข้างนอกไปหรอกไม่อยู่ที่
บ้านราคาบ้านใช่มั้ยอยู่บ้าน
นะก็กูฟ้าฟ้าอันนี้อยู่ในบ้าน
ออกไปนอกบ้านจะไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
เขา
แล้วก็ไม่รู้อะไรน่ะ
อยู่ในกระเป๋าใช่ไหมถ่าย
[เพลง]
เล็กๆใช่มั้ยคะคู่ฟ้า
ห้องเล็กค่ะเล็กประมาณนี้
อะ
[เพลง]
พี่ไปไหมคะ
ฉีดไม่ได้ค่ะคุยเสียงไม่ได้
เป็นเป็นเหมือนน้ำไม่เข้าเป็นน้ำไม่ให้
เป็นขวดไหมคะไม่ชัดไม่ใช่ครูอ๋อคิดว่า
เสร็จกับเป็นผู้หญิงนะผู้หญิงจะมีล้อ
ก็จะมีผู้หญิงมีผู้ชายไม่มี
ผู้ชายอาจจะน้อยผู้ชายหน่อยอาจจะมีแต่ผู้
หญิงจะมี
สี่เหลี่ยมไหมคะเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมไหม
พี่เหลี่ยมก็ได้วงกลมก็ได้ขัวใจก็ได้
อะไรอาอยู่ในกระเป๋าอ่ะอ้าวเป็นห่วงแต่
หัวใจอ่ะหัวใจก็ได้ให้ใช่ไหมหัวใจไหมคะมี
ซิป
ไม่มีซิปค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่มีสิทธิ์
โอเคข้างในมีเหรียญไหมไม่มีข้างในค่ะไม่
มีหรอมันยากนิดนึงนะกูไปให้กินนะค่ะ
เอาไว้
Type  R ขอเช็ค
รักเราคลิกแลรู้โหลๆเกิดอ่า
เอาไว้ดู
หน้าตัวเองใช่ไหมคะ
ไทยค่ะดูใช่ไหมตอนนี้ครูเอ๋ดูครูฟ้านะคะ
ดูไปอะเนี่ยเอาไว้ดูหน้าตัวเองบางทีดูฟัน
a รู้แล้วกูเองไม่มี
ไม่มี
กระจกเงา
[เพลง]
กระจกกระจกเงากระจก
วันนี้เลย
จะจบป่าว
กระจกวงกลมอ่าของครูฟ้าเป็นวงกลมเล็กๆ
เนาะกลมเล็กๆนะคะเป็นพูดท้ายหน้าผู้หญิง
ใช้ผู้ชายให้หน่อยไม่รู้รู้เมื่อก่อนครู
เอ๋มีตอนนี้ไม่มีตอนนี้กู A ใช้โทรศัพท์
เช็คใช่ไหมเช็คตีเช็คฟันค่ะ
อะไรแบบนี้ให้เวลาแต่งหน้าใช่ไหมคะก็ดู
กระจกเงานะคะ
โอเคต่อไปเดี๋ยวกูอ่ะลบอันนี้ก่อน
ได้โล่ ami  ami ของโอเค
ครูมา
ถาม
เป็นของกินใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะอ่ะ
มีของกินอ่ายิน
เป็น
ผลไม้ใช่ไหมคะเป็นผลไม้
ยังองุ่นองุ่นเป็นผลไม้
ไม่ไม่ใช่ผลไม้ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
เพราะว่า
เป็น
ขนมใช่ไหมคะขนมเค้กคุกกี้
อะไรนะอ่ามาจะลองเพลง
เป็นขนมผิงก้นอะไรที่เป็นขนาดใช่ขนมค่ะ
ไม่ใช่ขนมไม่ใช่กูเองไม่ค่อยกินขนมลือ
[เพลง]
ถ้าเป็นน้ำใช่ไหมคะเป็นน้ำอันนี้ใช่ไหม
หนาว
[เพลง]
r&b น้ำแต่ไม่ใช่เป็นน้ำ
มีน้ำแต่ไม่ใช่เป็นน้ำมีน้ำสระไม่ใช่น้ำ
เหรอใช่ไม่ใช่ขนมคือไม่ใช่ขนมมีไหมอยาก
ได้ยินไหมอะไรค่ะคุณเอ๋อ่า
ข้าวผัด
ข้าวเหมือนข้าวอ่ะนี่ยินหรือว่าจะเลยไม่
ใช่มั้ยสาย
มีเมย์อันนี้ใช่มะอ่า
กินหรือเฉลยอ่ะมีข้าวใช่ไหมคะข้าวมีกระทะ
5 กระทั้น
ขอรับข้าวลงมาแล้วก็มีตะหลิว
ตะหลิวอาร์
เมอร์มีน้ำมันเนาะ
น้ำมันใส่มีกระเทียมทำไม่ได้อันนี้มัน
เฉลยเลยเนาะ
ใส่แล้วก็ผัดกับขับแล้วก็เอาข้าวใส่เอา
กับขับ 5
อันนี้เอาอาจจะมี
พอแล้วพอดีกว่าข้าวผัด
กินข้าวผัด
ข้าวผัดกระเทียมอ้าไม่รู้กระเทียมอันนี้
หินล่ะไม่ใช่เฉลยหินหินอ้ากินคือข้าวผัด
เป็นของกินแล้วก็กินข้าวผัดของกินมีผู้
ขัด
อะไรอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าคิดถึงข้าวผัด
[เพลง]
คิดถึงข้าวผัด
เป็นผักใช่ไหมคะผัดแครอทบล็อกโคลี่เป็น
ผักอาอันนี้ของกินเป็นผักใช่ค่ะ
มะนาวค่ะมะนาว
มะนาวสีเขียวเนาะ
มะนาว
ท่ามะนาวกุ๊
เวลากินแล้วอ่ะคุณปรีเรียวจะอ่ามะนาวของ
ของของนักประเทศนักเรียนจะมีตัวนี้
ประเทศนักเรียนจะมีตัวที่เป็น
Lemon น่องของนักเรียนจะเป็น Lemon ของ
คนไทยจะเป็นมะนาว
ไม่ใช่ข้า
ไม่เปรี้ยวแต่
แตงกวาค่ะ
คุยกินทำไมเนี่ย
มา 2 อย่าง
มีต้นหอมอีกนะ
แตงกวาว่าถูกใจไหมอ่ะอ่ะ
มี
ค่าใดมีน้ำใช่มั้ยข้างในมีน้ำแต่งตัวแล้ว
เก่งๆแต่งกว่าลูกค้าอีก 1 อย่างค่ะไม่ทัน
แล้วบอกเอ๋ก็แล้วโอ้ยเวลาแล้วก็เวลาแล้ว
ไปพักอยู่แล้วมั้ง
งั้นวันนี้นักนักเรียนนะคะนักเรียนก็รู้
จักของใช้ของดินฐานอ่ะครูเอ๋มี
ของกินเป็น
องุ่นองุ่นเป็นผลไม้นะคะผลไม้
แล้วก็มีผัดนะคะแตงกวาแตงกว่าเป็นของกิน
แล้วก็มี
กล้องน้ำล้างอาจานร้านเช้านะคะเป็นของใช้
ครูฟ้ามีอะไรนะคะลูกค้ามีลิปสติกค่ะค่ะ
ลิปสติกเนี่ยเป็นของใช้นะฮะๆแล้วก็ใช้ที่
ไหนนะใช้ที่ปากค่ะไปที่ปากทาป่านะคะปาก
พระแล้วและมีอะไรนะกระจกกระจกเงาไว้ 2
หน้าหรือไว้ดูหน้านะคะ
จกหนาๆเป็นของใครนะเส้นของใช้ของใช้แชร์
หมดเวลาใช่ไหม
หมดเวลาแล้ว
งูนักเรียนได้ค่ะหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าบาทนะ
คะ
ยังไม่อยากรู้จักของกินของใช้อีกก็
คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะอ่าอ่ะและก็อยากรู้นัก
เรียนคนไหนคิดและไชโยปิงป่องคอมเม้นข้าง
ล่างนะคะได้เลยค่ะส่วนวันนี้ครูฟ้ากับครู
เอกก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะนักเรียนค่ะเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายค่ะพี่ขาอ่อนจาก
ไปอะไรครับคือป่าหรือคุณกดนี้กดแชร์กด
Subscribe มหานักเรียนควร
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่า